we actively seek out people who will
tell the truth on this subject there
aren't many bob woodson is one of them
he's of course a civil rights icon a
frequent guest on this show and we're
delighted to have him joining us tonight
mr woodson thanks so much for coming on
why won't thank you it's so obvious
what's happening it's been going on for
50 years if there's one thing that's
wrecked the country it's this why won't
anybody say it
well because it's not politically
correct to say that because they're
buying into the race the whole race
theory
that somehow the problems that black
america faces today is a legacy of
slavery and jim crow and it's patently
not true
and we at the woodson center has
demonstrated this with delano who is a
part of our group too with just
wonderful statement
but in fact dads are stepping up and
they have been around the country
we saw this in louisiana
when kids were fighting in in their
schools
for three days and they were arrested
these these black dads didn't go to the
school and demand that teachers receive
dei training instead they said these are
our children destroying one another and
destroying their future we have the
responsibility and the obligation to
respond so five of them got together and
went into the school and then it soon
expanded to 40 men and these dads are
patrolling the schools uh going to
classes they work with local law
enforcement to get to make sure that the
dads were screened going in it's a part
of a movement tucker that's been going
on for a number of years uh uh that the
woodson center has supported groups like
this
in fact we spent about five hundred
thousand dollars giving five thousand
dollar grants to grassroots groups like
this dad's group uh in the country and
i'm just pleased that they get getting
the kind of public recognition that they
need and what they need though isn't
more upwards they need rewards we need
to shift some of the money that's being
wasted
by corporations on black lives matter
and spend the money
uh people inside these communities the
solutions are where the problems are
well of course if you ask any successful
well-adjusted productive man in this
country you know why you know what's the
secret to your happiness most of them
will say you know my dad had a lot to do
with it that's just true everyone knows
it's true i cannot believe we're
ignoring this
but we are because
i'm not sure why
well because it's not politically
correct that i think the radical left
has defined has been using black america
as a political tool
yeah and they are exploiting the whole
race issue
for their own gain
but but and so the only way that that's
going to change to be challenged is to
allow black america to speak for
themselves and that's what the woodson
center is doing we're going to be
expanding on our grants program and we
hope to go out and reach others to
convince them that we need to invest
in these uh these dads they recognize
that they are willing to be surrogate
fathers to hundreds of other children
and so we we hope and pray that the
country will wake up instead of
seeing george soros spend a million
dollars
in in texas town to promote defunded
police we need to invest instead on
these grassroots healing agents
not only to to heal the the community
from within
white america can't do a thing to solve
the problems of black america making
white people less racist doesn't make
black people much safer
than
that
exactly
that's
true for everyone robert woodson thank
you very much great to see you tonight
thank you tucker hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else